Wikipedia's relentless march forward to
become the planets spanning one stop
information center for millions of
people all over the world has claimed a
few victims along the way the printed
encyclopedia business for example has
pretty much imploded in the last couple
decades with me in the studio was a man
who experienced that firsthand
Alexandre Bob used to head up block
house one of Germany's best-known
encyclopedia publishers welcome to the
show
first of all that exactly could you
explain to us exactly what went wrong
because I believe your business already
had its own online model up and ready
but the company as a whole got sold
Yeah right from from the beginning we
watched Wikipedia in Germany and we saw
that a very dynamic development and so
we decided to put up something ourselves
and but a peer-to-peer encyclopedia
which means we would involve institutes
and named authors to build up an online
for free encyclopedia as well but it
didn't happen no it did finally didn't
happen
could it have competed against Wikipedia
we don't know we will never know
probably but we had a concept and we had
a business model and the project was
ready to be switched on but exactly at
that time Bacchus was sold from the
owner to two bertelsmann so when you see
Wikipedia when you hear the word
Wikipedia what what does that mean for
you and I'm very Pro Wikipedia I must
say because it's free information for so
many people it's a revolution on that
and the increasing knowledge of our time
has to be put up somewhere but I think
there's room for an alternative an
alternative a peer-to-peer alternative
with institutions providing the
information wouldn't that go against
what Wikipedia is for though we keep
pedia is for the people and by the
people and as soon as you get an
institution involved I mean not all
institutions are going to be as reliable
as say some of the institutions I'm sure
you're thinking about
I'm not sure if Wikipedia will be able
to keep up the speed necessary without
increasing the income well their
foundation but still they have to get
money from from the foundation if it
could get bigger and bigger and bigger
and so big that it's collapses its
collapses for that model they are
following and maybe the it's time then
for a different model where the users
pay for information but they know from
which source they are buying the
information would that involve
advertising that at some stage yeah
maybe advertising what's wrong with
advertising if you know that somebody
has paid for advertising being close to
an article that doesn't necessarily mean
that the article is influenced by that
people I mean we have so many magazines
in Vince Jimmy Wales of that way yeah I
mean at Wikipedia we don't know who
wrote the article with what intent if
you buy a Spiegel magazine you know that
there is advertising but you would never
say that there's an influence of the
advertisement into the content and and
and then there's the content itself what
subjects are actually being covered if
you take a look at Wikipedia 16% of the
1.3 million biographies on English
Wikipedia are about women what about all
the rest of the influential women in the
world when it comes to Africa only
two-and-a-half percent of the geotag
content is about the entire content of
Africa which is the second biggest
content continent in the world yeah it's
it's much more difficult to get people
to make articles Wikipedia wants that
was easier when we had this Bracco's at
editors and we could tell them well we
need more on Africa we with no more on
women we need more on that topic that
was easier to make but on the other hand
Wikipedia today has much more
information than brokers could provide
in books on bookshelves and it's for
free so it's the best available at the
moment so I know
where you'd like to see Wikipedia move
but where do you think it will end up in
the next years it's been around for 16
years or so where will it end up do you
think I think they need to go in a
direction which professional
professional eyes more and have more
editors taking care of certain topics
and let's say pay for content to be on
Wikipedia at least the first article
it's always easier then to correct and
add things to an article that already
exists I think is that's the way they
have to go
Alexandre Bob thank you very much for
coming in today thank you